some of the magic of Poker is the little
sample I agree like for example in sorry
to be bringing up Magnus so much but
there's so much parallel between the two
of you and the poker in the Chess World
he hates Olympics and World
Championships and all that kind of stuff
because it's so low sample but to me
that's part of the magic of it there's
the World Series of Poker the main event
there's a magic to it I agree yeah and I
don't know what that is exactly because
so much at stake is so rare
so much drama and heartbreak leading up
to it that all somehow
yeah it it accumulates to
that magical moment when somebody wins
especially that event the World Series
poker Main Event historically like
that's it you know that's the Pinnacle
that's where like mainstream watches
that's where people are tuning in and
the gravity of the moment you know it's
so much bigger than people like everyone
gets the opportunity to play armchair
quarterback too right oh he should do
this you're not there you're not under
the lights you're not under the pressure
you know it might seem easy for you at
home to be like well yeah because you
can see the whole cards you know they
can't certainly the idea of
the small sample of tournaments I like
the idea that
you don't have to worry about oh well if
I do this now then in the future you
know I won't be balanced I have to be
balanced here or anything like that
that's like really boring and lame right
again that is kind of the way the
younger generation learns how to play
the game being balanced in every spot
um and then randomizing you know like oh
I'm supposed to do this 50 of time okay
so if my left card is red I'll do it and
if it's black I don't so you're not even
making you're no longer making actual
decisions for yourself you're just
randomizing and that's way less fun for
me than tailoring it to the situation
and the final table at the main event
there's none of that you have to I mean
it's It's All or Nothing well you
shouldn't be but there are like again I
think a lot of the young guys they are
thinking in that regard like oh
randomization maybe at that table the
final table at the main event uh what's
a hand that stands out to you that was
especially gutsy and Powerful or
memorable for that you've seen in the
history of Poker well for me the one
that stands out and probably because I
was so young and it was my first year
like one of my well I won a bracelet
that year was I was friends with Scotty
Wynn the prince of Poker and he was
heads up against the guy named Kevin
McBride and I was on the rail you know
I'm like wow he's gonna you know he's
heads up and he was so cool like he had
a mullet but it's perfect right you get
the white shirt the black thing he's
drinking a Michelob smoking a cigarette
whatever you know all chill
he bets it all in the river and the
guy's thinking and he psychologically
owned him and he said he goes with his
beard goes you call gonna be all over
baby Ah that's right okay so this guy
who was an amateur heard that and was
like there's so much pressure in this
moment right now I can't handle this
pressure but Scotty just told me if I
call here it's the pressure's gone I
don't have to be under it anymore so he
sort of hypnotized them into making the
call you know and Scotty had it Scotty
had you know the Full House and it was
over for the guy you call gonna be all
over baby it was I just I love that
aspect sort of the table talk Dynamic
which isn't as prevalent today as it was
back then
um but that one sticks out and probably
because it was one of my first it's so
uh
the few words you say at the table can
can completely affect a hand like that
that's that's almost that's scary
it was just so cool to me you know like
just how he was so calm and I think that
too added more pressure to the amateur
and I think like Again part of it is
even back then it was 1998 there's still
a big rail of people and there's lights
and they're you know they're filming and
all this kind of stuff and it's a lot of
pressure for a guy who's never been in
this environment and now I'm telling you
it can all be over soon
it will all be over soon just call it's
finished